in ipso's polling exclusive to global
news nearly half of canadians say while
they may not agree with everything
that's being said the protesters
frustration is legitimate and worthy of
sympathy a slim majority think the
opposite when it comes to how canadians
feel about people in the protests
canadians are not as sympathetic six in
ten think it's mostly a group of
anti-vaxxers and bigots intent on
causing mayhem and they should not be
allowed to protest a majority also think
the protest is an attack on democracy
what really stands out from the polling
because we asked a number of questions
is that this is less about the truckers
and their tactics and a lot more about
the general mood and general set of
issues that they're talking about that
is connected with canadians and 46
percent of canadians saying that they
may not agree with everything the
trucker convoy says or does but that
they agree with the frustration so they
believe it's legitimate and worthy of
our sympathy that's that's a number that
stands out that's younger people who are
most uh interested in the message of the
people who are uh
occupying uh downtown ottawa and maybe
with what they're doing at the uh at the
various bridges and other places along
with people who are less affluent so
their their belief in all of this is
that this is less about the politics and
more about genuine suffering that's
taking place among a group of the
population that they can sympathize with
uh as far as the politics are concerned
um
you know parts of all voting groups that
you take a look at are either on side or
offside uh with what the what the
truckers are up to but there isn't
unanimity in any political party right
at the moment it's not that canadians
necessarily agree with blocking
parliament hill or blocking bridges or
particularly things that uh
reflect badly on the political
motivations of people who might you know
some of the fringe elements who might be
involved that are you know have nazi
sympathies or expressing misogynist or
racist types of attitudes the canadians
have no no relationship to that at all
and do not support it but that general's
sentiment about frustration
that's really connecting with the
canadian population right now and if
they don't get some resolution the
expectation based on what we're seeing
here is that this level of support will
continue to grow
we asked canadians whether or not they
agreed or disagreed with the prime
minister's position that he should not
be negotiating with the truck protesters
53 percent of canadians uh agree that he
shouldn't be so they agree with the
prime minister certainly more than
actually voted for him in the last
election but that's only half of
canadians the other half of canadians
say that he should be at least giving it
a try so um
the the level of support behind the
government in terms of the position that
they've taken uh regarding these
protests is not strong it's it's quite
divided and fragile and where it seems
to be going is against what the
government's position is so um saying
that you're not going to negotiate not
trying to find some way of getting out
of this
that involves some sort of discussion is
something that's going to be difficult
to sustain over time